[Music]
this week on
forward you want to know why nonprofits
haven't changed the world the way we hop
that they would because that is not what
we ask them to do we ask them
emphatically and consistently and we
still do keep your overhead and your
salaries low so that's what they did and
if you keep your overhead and your
salaries low we will reward you with
donations regardless of the fact that
you may not be having any impact in the
world an impact becomes an entire irely
secondary
[Music]
thing it's my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast a hero of mine entrepreneur
author activist nonprofit leader you
might know him from his world famous Ted
Talks plural Dan pado welcome Dan thanks
for having me Andrew it's good to be
with you so I left out movie star you
are the star of a new documentary that I
thought was brilliant and as we're
having this conversation it may be on
streamers right now uncharitable tell me
a little bit I by the I watched the
movie and I thought it was awesome um
but how the heck did this movie come
about and let's go a little bit further
just so people who don't know you I feel
like everyone should know who you are if
you don't know who Dan pilat is
literally Google right now Dan plot Ted
talk it'll be the best 15 minutes you
spend uh for quite some time but somehow
that Ted Talk evolved into a
full-fledged documentary feature yeah it
started with a book I wrote for toughs
University press in 2009 called
uncharitable after I had created the
AIDS rides and the breast cancer 3 days
and we raised almost $600 million in N
years and um were the subject of Harvard
Business School case study and but but
during the uh journey of that success we
were pretty regularly mercilessly
crucified for having high overhead and
paying people
uh good salaries and you know I was sort
of cataloging all of these dysfunctional
ways our culture thinks about charity
while we were building that company and
while it was succeeding and and knew
that I wanted to write a book about it
um we went out of business suddenly in
2002 because of those issues and then I
wrote the book and um and I knew when I
wrote the book that it would be good
subject matter for a documentary it was
uh I was going to Ted I went think I
went to Ted in 2005 and six and seven
and and saw Al Gore give his Ted Talk
and then watched as that became a movie
and I thought the issues we cover in
this book would be great for documentary
it just took a long time to raise the
money for it and for for it to be sort
of as Victor Hugo would have said an
idea whose time has come in terms of
making it into a documentary
documentaries are tough sledding uh I
have been parts of
documentaries uh and so this documentary
flushes out the argument you made in
your Ted Talk and I thought the Ted Talk
was very compelling and correct in part
because in a past life I started and ran
a nonprofit um so I I have some jokes
around starting nonprofits uh that
nonprofits run on two things passion and
money and uh um and one of the dark
truths of being a nonprofit founder is
that the way to get the money is to talk
about the passion um but then even as
you're talking about the passion you're
thinking okay how do I get the
money right right right yeah and and if
you think about it a lot of times people
in the nonprofit sector will say you
know we have to beg for money we have to
beg for money well guess what
entrepreneurs have to beg for money too
it's not just the nonprofit sector where
you're begging for money it's in the
nonprofit sector you we people have
miniaturized Ambitions as Susan
barisford at the Ford Foundation used to
say about how much money they're
entitled to like in the non in the
nonprofit sector doesn't distinguish the
concept of capital nonprofits think of
their Capital as whatever is in their
petty cash so if they get $23,000 in
their petty cash that's the money they
can use to create something new whether
that's a new fundraising Endeavor or a
new program well that's not how
entrepreneurs in the for-profit sector
think about it they think about what
scale do I want this idea to um enter
the marketplace at how much money would
it cost to bring it out at that scale
and let me go to the capital markets and
get that much money so I can do it right
their dreams aren't um limited by the
amount of money in the bank account I
mean imagine if if Elon mus I can't
remember whether he bought SpaceX or
Tesla first but let's say he bought
Tesla first and he wants to start SpaceX
well it doesn't look at the the the the
petty cash in Tesla to go start SpaceX
right he goes to the capital markets to
do that and so this um over oversight of
the concept and power of capital in the
nonprofit sector is is a big problem and
it's driven by the fact that the that
the sector has been so oppressed um that
that so many of the freedoms we give to
business have been taken away from the
nonprofit sector in the name of some
kind of an ethic uh and and and you know
the bottom line message of the movie and
the Ted Talk is you want to know why
nonprofits haven't changed the world the
way we hoped that they would because
that is not what we ask them to do we
ask them emphatically and consistently
and we still do keep your overhead and
your salaries low so that's what they
did and if you keep your overhead and
your salaries low we will reward you
with donations regardless of the fact
that you may not be having any impact in
the world and impact becomes an entirely
secondary thing yeah that I I have
stories along uh those lines I have two
stories I will share for fun um so check
it out I started a nonprofit Venture for
America uh I donated some money of my
own to start it uh and then I went
around and shook down some rich friends
for money um a number of years later we
had had some success and it was our Gala
well number one I said Galas are stupid
uh let's skip the gala and just have
everyone send money in place of the gala
and then they can have the night to
themselves and so I tried that and it
totally didn't work that it turns out no
one wanted to money unless they could go
to something and then the gala does
lubricate their Pur strings in a certain
way because they see all these other
people and they're like oh this course
it's great and they get the messaging
and then they end up so number one you
needed to have the gala uh number two at
this Gala maybe my fourth year in I'm
hanging out with a venture capitalist in
New York and he said Andrew you are a
great entrepreneur this is a great
organization if you were a for-profit
company you'd be a unicorn by
now right he Lally said like it was a
high compliment he was like your
nonprofit is the equivalent of a billion
dollar startup um but of course it is
not a billion dollar startup it was a
nonprofit with a budget of let's call it
$5 million or something along those
lines um but but it just gave you a
sense of the different scale that he had
in his mind is that you know billion
dollar for-profit company equals $5
million nonprofit uh and then the the
third story is I was uh getting a grant
from
major financial institution uh and the
CEO comes and uh gives us social
entrepreneurs uh frankly a pretty bad
pep talk and then talking about how what
that now that we have the resources we
can go out and change the world and
literally I think my organization got
$25,000 from this particular Grant and
you're and so that there was something
ridiculous about it it's like wait a
minute like we all know you're a
multi-billionaire and this is a major
finan institution and then you give us
25k and then it's like and now with with
this
incredible uh level of resources like go
out to do something awesome it's like
man I could point to anyone in your
building and it's like $25,000 covers
them for you know like three
months or or actually some of them
probably like you know two weeks one
week so uh so there there was like this
ludicrous differential when it came to
uh what constituted a successful
nonprofit versus what's what constitut a
successful business and the the
standards were so different that it it
it felt like you said like oh wow look
you're actually doing something like
isn't that great and then everyone acts
all um excited about it but as someone
who was leading the organization I was
like look I know I'm not actually
meaningfully uh making progress in
solving the big problem but I'm very
proud of the work I'm doing and
obviously if you give me 25k I'm going
to be very very thankful and be like oh
thank you thank you even though though
it turally I was like guys you know this
isn't going to do it yeah we were with
the AIDS rides and the breast cancer
three days as of 2002 we were netting
netting after all expenses about $81
million a year now if you put a six a
multiple of 506 on that right you got a
half billion 3/4 billion dollar company
and people would ask me oh that's great
that you do that um do you
volunteer like the misconceptions like
no there are 400 full-time people
involved paid employees involved in
making that happen and and I think what
you talking about you know the $25,000
gift is indicative of the idea of of the
fact that we don't
consider the nonprofit sector to be to
have the potential to be a lead player
in changing the world we don't don't
think that the nonprofit sector can
could do that we think of it as a
gesture we think of it as something nice
that uh you know people dabble in when
they're when they're retired or when
they're um done with their day and and
and and it's why um I challenge anyone
to go back and and listen to all of the
presidential debates of the last five
decades and and see if you hear the
nonprofit sector mentioned once as a
critical element of how we solve
problems for or the least Among Us um
and and as it's currently constrained
it's not it's not capable of taking on
that role but if we released it from
these anachronistic anachronistic
constraints and what do I mean by that I
mean well we don't allow nonprofits to
use money to attract the absolute best
people to solve problems we don't allow
nonprofits to advertise so that they can
excite the general public about the work
that they're doing and grow we don't
allow them to take risks when it comes
to new fundraising and new ways to grow
we we measure them in 12month increments
so we don't give them any time and we
don't give them a capital market and the
for-profit sector gets all of those
things well if you gave all of those
things to the nonprofit
sector it could address the issues with
the help of business and government but
could take the lead in addressing the
issues of poverty that still remain at
14% in the United States illiteracy
that's been at 14 % for the last four
decades breast cancer where the
mortality has been around hovering
around 40,000 for the last four decades
with no change suicide where the
mortality now approaches 40,000 up from
10 years ago all of these problems are
problems where the nonprofit sector is
uniquely doing on the ground R&D that
nobody else is doing to figure out what
Innovations might work at solving those
problems um but they don't have the
scale the the the problems are massive
in scale massive in scale these are
multi-billion decim million decillion
decillion problems and we want our
Charities to be small and when they
start to get too big we think oh I'm
going to give to this other charity
because they they're big enough well not
if they haven't solved the problem
they're not big enough right well the
the ideal nonprofit puts itself out of
business which as you're saying never
happens because nonprofits aren't
actually uh designed to hit a scale
where they can solve the problem yeah
and one I'm sorry to interrupt but one
of the things that kills me is this
notion that people say well we need to
make our nonprofit sustainable nobody
wants your nonprofit to be sustainable
they they they want you to go out of
business I had a client called me five
years ago said we're we're celebrating
our 50th Anniversary as a breast cancer
organization 25th anniversary as a
breast cancer organization we want to
tell people everything we're going to do
in the next 25 years I mean do do you do
you realize how ironic that people don't
want breast cancer to be around in
another 25 years they don't want to be
celebrating anniversaries they want
these problems to be end
it this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn when you go to the bathroom
you always close the door behind you
because you don't want random people
seeing what you're doing but when you go
online people sometimes can see what
you're doing I'm talking about those big
tech companies and other folks who might
not have your best interest at heart
that's why I use expressvpn and you
should too this way your data stays
yours it can't be sold and resold when I
use expressvpn you just click one button
transports you to another server and
also give you access to fun content that
might be available in another country
it's like you're a global traveler
without ever leaving your home get an
extra 3 months of expressvpn free by
going to expressvpn
/y that's EX
sbn.com yangang for three extra months
free expressvpn.com
[Music]
slang yeah so I I want to uh break down
for people a little bit how the uh
growth factors are totally different um
just from my own experience so check it
out I ran an education company
and let's say I did a really good job
for you uh and then you tell your friend
and then your friend's like oh maybe I
should use this company too and then
they tell their friend and so the better
job I do the more I grow um in the
nonprofit segment let's say I was
helping um hungry people if I help a
hungry person well um maybe they tell
their friend who's also hungry who shows
up but but that actually has nothing to
do with my grow grow in terms of uh
donations like you you have a totally
different Marketplace you're dealing
with yes in in the form of donors as
opposed to people you provide services
for so my my comparison my joke was that
it's like running a chocolate chip
cookie stand but your customers aren't
eating the
cookies like they're not allowed and so
you just build brochures being like look
how tasty my cookies are can't you tell
how much they're enjoying them and so
there's something you know like much
more direct about and but this by the
way was an education for me because I
was a CEO of a small private company um
before I started the nonprofit and the
growing the nonprofit was a much more
difficult painstaking Endeavor than
growing the for-profit business yeah
it's very astute your distinction about
growth you know I do do workshops with
nonprofit organizations I might have 300
people in a room on a Saturday all board
members from different organizations and
staff and and and consistently ly
somebody will say we're we're growing by
Leaps and Bounds and I'll say oh that's
great so how much more money did you
raise this year than last year oh we
didn't raise any more money okay what do
you mean by growth well we've got twice
as many people who want our services for
free right well that's not growth that's
a problem right if you've got twice as
much demand but you don't have the money
to meet the demand then that then that's
a that's a real problem yeah so so let's
say the growth factors in the nonprofit
Iran would have been around okay let me
get more donors you know and then you
you hustle up more more donors and by
the way we did grow in that way I mean I
put in some money and so our budget in
year one might have been 200,000 250 um
and then it went up to five million plus
and so people were like wow like you
know this is like a real rocket ship so
the organization I started was called
Venture for America um the goal was to
train entrepreneurs uh to create
companies and jobs around the country in
the hope of uplifting and invigorating
the economy and the culture U my thesis
was that we had too many young people
heading to Wall Street consulting firms
and the rest of it uh Court law school
um and that uh they should be building
things uh and creating jobs so uh I
realized that our organization was never
going to be able to
create hundreds of thousands or millions
of jobs in the way that I I wanted to um
and I ended up running for president
because the trends that I was concerned
about around automation uh and its
effect on the labor market were just
speeding up uh so I said oh snap you
know my awesome $5 million nonprofit's
not GNA like be able to to meaningfully
stop that tide what what could stop that
tide um and it was only a different
economy um with the federal government
which is one reason why I'm so excited
by your work Dan because you've
documented essentially look the
nonprofit sector is capped at a low
level um I think you said it was 2% of
um the economy or so and that's constant
um also relatively constant the poverty
level you know it's like hey if we're
making such great progress like why have
these numbers not changed meaningfully
uh and I concluded the only way to fix
things would be to get a hold of the
federal government and then re remake
the economy uh that led to my
presidential run um I I dare say that
you probably should have run for
president at some point I think that
that was even in the ambition set at at
some
point it was when I was a was was a kid
you know I I I was born on the first day
of John Kennedy's presidency so when I
was 78 and N I was surrounded by the
images of Robert Kennedy and Martin
Luther King and John Kennedy and his his
inspirational words and I was watching
my parents watch the Vietnam War and I
was watching the Mercury and in Gemini
and Apollo missions happen and watching
Neil Armstrong walk on the moon and it
it made me you know want to bring that
Kennedy like Vision into the world my my
timing was off in that I I happen to be
gay and and uh you know when I was 19
years old I ran for the school board in
my hometown and one and and that's when
I was really realizing that I was gay
and and there were no out gay
politicians in in 198 n and and I began
to get scared that you know people are
going to out me and they're going to
think I'm to they're going to think I
want to recruit kids to be gay and
that's why I'm on the school committee
so I better I better back out of this
situation and and I moved to California
and tried to get a record deal as a
musician and then that's where I ended
up starting the starting the uh the AIDS
rides but I remember you know feeling
just very estranged from my country as a
gay person in 1980 like what do we teach
kids we teach them try find the thing
your passion passionate about and go do
it and so many kids can't you know it's
just like I don't know what I'm
passionate about and to know what you're
passionate about and say this is the
thing I want to do and then have Society
say yeah you can't that it was crushing
you know it was crushing but um you know
You Follow the yellow brick road and you
you you meet the times where they're at
and your life contributes in un
unexpected ways and I look at it as look
this is this is not the sexiest issue
getting people to think differently
about charity getting people to liberate
Charities but it's the service that I
it's the service to which I feel I have
been called because that sector needed
leadership and I think it can make if
we're successful in changing the way the
culture thinks about charity the
difference that can be made there is is
enormous perhaps bigger than what you
could do as
president
hey YouTube thanks for watching please
do hit like And subscribe and hit that
Bell if you want to be notified every
time a new episode drops probably on
Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you no no D Dan I'm gonna introduce to
you because here we're we're chasing a
common Vision check it out all right Le
let's say that AI is going to make a
bunch of jobs obsolete it's going to
come along and say you know what
bookkeepers accountants some lawyering
some coding some Consulting some
trading like some journalism and so
that's one force I'm going to call this
the automation Force it's going to
dehumanize the economy progressively in
my opinion the current economy actually
is becoming increasingly punitive and uh
inhuman and so people ask me hey what is
the future of the economy and when I was
running for president I said said just
give everyone money Universal basic
income um a th000 bucks a month was what
I was running on but here's the true
vision and I said this in my early
campaign events Dan and my campaign
manager said you can never say this
again it's hard enough getting people to
handle the magical Asian man from the
future wants to give everyone money uh
but what what I
said was look uh our economy is going to
make it so more and more of us are not
competitive in terms of capital
efficiency um but there are all of these
goals that we should have for ourselves
as a society um that aren't about me
outc competing the machine or whatnot
things around arts and creativity or
caring and nurturing or education uh
health and self-development um or making
someone else stronger um and healthier
either physically or mentally so uh um
so what I said was look we're going to
have to create new
currencies um to allow people to find
structure purpose and fulfillment taking
these routes uh that may not right now
have a Marketplace and the activity I
used as an example was my wife as a
caregiver to our son who's autistic and
then I said what is the marketplace
value of her work and someone would say
I don't know zero because that's what we
value caregivers at right uh right now
and I said well let's imagine if I help
my neighbor or I uh babysit their kids
or I create a mural or I volunteer or I
do something like I I get this currency
that I can then give to you I can give
to my other neighbor uh and then we can
essentially create like a new more human
economy and then we create a creativity
currency that you could actually trade
in for US dollars so everyone knows it's
real and then who administers the
creativity currency probably nonprofits
was my thought what you'd go to
nonprofits in the space and say hey
guess what like we're going to give you
a million creativity credits and you can
do whatever you want with them to reward
good things uh and and if you want to
you can redeem them and there's money so
I I can give you things that aren't US
dollars well first of all I would say I
I worry about AI I I worry about just
mechanical automation even more you know
when you look at how many fewer welds
are required to build a Tesla now than
were required before when you look at
the um all of the robots and how few
people are in a Tesla Factory when you
look at uh you know and I don't know
what the cause and effect and the
unintended consequences Dynamics are but
when you look at minimum wages go up and
then you see Donald's starting to put
kiosks for ordering your food you go to
crumble cookies and you oh no Dan Dan
I've I've got a whole freaking uh deck
on this stuff where where where 65% of
Americans are not high school graduates
uh oh sorry are not college graduates um
the the top five occupation areas in the
US are administrative and clerical work
including call centers retail and sales
food service and food prep truck driving
and transportation and Manufacturing uh
so that so that's what about half of
Americans do um average comp
compensation about 18 bucks an hour and
each of those is going to shrink quick
and and that's without what Tesla is
doing with robots and Boston Dynamic is
doing with robots is we'll move boxes
from here to here right like just
physical labor that's it's it's
terrifying I I I step back and I I think
about um the vision that Buckminster
Fuller had you know this famous
mathematician and philosopher and he
talked about he got very specific which
is important a world that works for
everyone with no one and nothing left
out it's like when Kennedy said I
believe this nation should commit itself
to uh the goal before this decade is out
of Landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to the Earth like
if you weren't serious about that dream
it would never Dawn on you that got to
get the guy back safely as well but this
idea of a world that works for everyone
with no one and nothing left out okay
excluding the issues we're currently
talking about you know the market
economy seems to be able to get
developed economies 90% of the way there
87% of the way there we got 87% of
people taken care of you know whether
it's through capital or cell phones or
whatever it is you know we got most of
the problem taking care of infant
mortality rates are way down literacy
rates are up and all of the developed
countries yeah but that 133% that 10%
that got left behind the market economy
has no answers for those people why
because there's nothing to monetize
there right which which is what you were
talking about like how do you monetize
the value of taking care of an elderly
woman how do you monetize the love
someone gets out of Special Olympics and
that's where philanthropy comes in and
so you know you and I have talked about
the idea of the need for a a a
department of philanthropy I think a
department of philanthropy and social
Improvement at the at the level of of um
of the White House and have you seen
something called the impact Genome
Project uh that that they're they're
trying to do something along these lines
and and in the movie uncharitable it it
talks about uh paying people for results
where it's like look instead of I give
you the organization the money and then
you do some good work but you may or may
not solve the problem it's like look in
this instance I'm just going to pay you
for the good that is done uh and and so
and there have been things called social
impact bonds that were popular in the UK
primarily relegated to the issue of
prisons and recidivism it can just be
very difficult to develop those measures
especially when you're dealing with a
with a a long time Horizon for the
solving of a problem um it can be
difficult I I I I do want to address
your social credit issue and and and go
back to something you said earlier about
um about growth uh you were talking
about the you know the the the growth of
the problem versus the gross growth of
the revenue and I was as well but what
if a nonprofit is growing in the way
that you want they actually are
impacting the problem and Billy Shore
talked about this in the movie he said
you know here's what I tell a donor if I
can get you 1% over overhead but hunger
isn't being solved anywhere or I can get
you 35% overhead and hunger is being
solved in 40 of the 50 states which his
organization has done which is the
better deal for you well right now the
culture thinks of that 1% that's what I
want I I want 1% overhead and the
problem not getting solved so in the
case of an organization like no kid
hungry what they struggle with
is or other organizations we've got an
overhead ratio that could make us a
Target for the media to attack us and uh
and misconstrue what we're doing when in
fact we're actually ending hunger so we
don't we don't value the right things
but but I think in terms of your Social
credit idea and my idea of a world that
works for everyone with no one and
nothing left out you're going to get
more and more Consolidated money right
in the hands of Elon Musk and in the
hands of Jeff Bas and others and that's
where philanthropy and I would I would I
would tuck your idea into that becomes
more more important in becoming
scientific about philanthropy scientific
about what works scientific about
capitalizing the things that work not
just the things that pull on your
heartstrings but the things that are
actually working which is why I get
apoplectic when I see these tax the rich
um
declarations it's it's it's so lacking
in rigor what tax the rich and then do
what with the money then do yeah you
don't have a second sentence to that
like we don't know yeah like how about
identify yeah we don't know how about
identify solutions that work and then
I'm in favor of taxing the risks to fund
those if you're as you said earlier if
you're a
nonprofit and you want a $25,000 Grant
you go to a foundation you got to give
them all kinds of data on how you know
that this is working everything else but
the federal government oh just give us
lots of money we don't have any data on
anything that works but just give give
us the money right it's so lacking in
rigor it's so wasteful it drives me
insane big government versus small
government it's a false
dichotomy what about what's going to
solve problems it might be big
government but let's figure out what the
answers are and and and then have that
have the size of government follow the
methodology you
know how are you going to get healthier
this year one way to do so is have
healthy chef-crafted meals delivered to
your door stressfree what the heck am I
talking about Factor Factor's 2-minute
meals are your secret weapon to a
healthier happier you I've been eating
factor for this last number of weeks and
wow it's been a game changer we're
talking about delicious chicken taco
bowl spicy pablano beef and every time
I'm like ooh this is is going to be
tasty and it is makes you feel good it's
cost efficient it's flexible no prep no
mess you can't screw it up just poke a
couple holes in it heat it up and it's
fresh never Frozen I got to say if you
tri Factor you are going to be pumped
it's going to make you healthier happier
more productive in the New Year head to
factor meals.com Yang 50 and use code
Yang 50 to get 50% off that's code yang
y50 at factor meals.com
y50 to get 50% off
Factor yeah yeah you just want effective
systems I mean like there are examples
of things where and I think your movie
talks about it uh where a lot of money
might get be spent on homelessness in a
particular City and yet you go and it's
like hey homelessness actually hasn't
been meaning ful impacted or improved uh
you know there are places where we're
spending lots of money on education and
then it doesn't work and it's like oh
let's spend more money and there's
absolutely no
difference in Impact um and then if you
were to say the overhead is low and the
CEO has paid a low salary we love that
organization even though no difference
is being made that's the whole Twisted
lens through which we look at this stuff
yeah your your vision is vital for us to
get to a better place uh that your
Insight that look we treat philanthropy
as this kind of stepchild that we can
pat on the head and just you know like
pay lip service too but we don't
actually expect it to uh be competitive
we don't expect it to enlist the best
people and pay them whatever the market
rate is we don't expect them to solve
the problem uh we we expect them to keep
their costs
low like like regardless of what that
that might mean um one of the the things
you and I have in common is that we've
both been growth operators in different
contexts and when you're a growth
operator you actually find you need
awesome people and awesome people can
very much be Mission driven but awesome
people also need advancement and that
can include compensation advancement if
they're going to stick with you past a
certain number of years like like an
awesome person might show up and do
something uh great and cool for a
particular period of time but then
they'll say okay like getting drawn to
this other cool thing oh and by the way
this other thing will also pay me better
and I'm getting married and I'm having
kids and the rest of it I mean that
there's like an entire maturation cycle
so I would love to see you unlock the
philanthropic sector so that it is able
to compete on these Dimensions that you
listed which are uh compensation
advertising time
risk-taking um and what was the fifth
Capital oh yeah of course Capital
markets right um so those if we could do
that it would be uh awesome and you're
totally right that my idea for
currencies to uh reward positive
behaviors or measure prog progress and
performance would get folded into what
you imagine as like a much more robust
uh nonprofit sector um like What
proportion of the economy so let's say
right now the nonprofit sector is 2% of
the economy what do you think the the
target of the goal or the potential is I
think there are two two ways we can grow
the nonprofit sector one is increasing
donations and and in the Ted Talk I said
if we went from 2% of GDP to 3% of GDP
and that increase went dis
disproportionately to Health and Human
Services organizations that would be a
massive trans because right now it's
actually about a 1.2 1.3 trillion dollar
sector and if you think of it as a pie a
third of it is fees for services so
nonprofit hospitals that charge you or
museums that charge you a ticket a third
of it is government contracts and a
third of it is is philanthropy and
philanthropy is now getting close to
about half a trillion $500 billion do a
year but of that only about 18% is
Health and Human Services and only about
18% of philanthropy so you're you're
talking about you know maybe
uh 100 80 90 hundred billion dollars for
Health and Human Services well that's
where all the problems are that's where
all the suffering is that we want to
eradicate so if you allow those
organizations that are really doing the
best work to promote themselves and
bring in more donations and really grow
so that they could begin to address the
problem um you know an increase of
hundred billion dollar in in in
donations that went directly to that
sector would would be um transformative
but also the consolidation of the sector
is something that we need to look at
there are 1.5 million nonprofits in the
United States there are about a hundred
new nonprofits formed every day we
simply do not need 73,000 organizations
working on breast cancer right we need
one or two or three the way we have
Samsung and Apple but because we've
removed all Financial incentive from the
nonprofit sector because the money is
bad in the nonprofit sector wanting
money is bad there's no Financial
incentive to merge and and and money is
what motivates all the m&a activity in
the for-profit sector in the nonprofit
sector you just have holy points and so
if you merge you lose your holy points
and that's the last thing you want so
you know my best thinking on that is
provide some kind of financial incentive
maybe it's a tax credit not a deduction
a credit you know dude the Secretary of
philanthropy you're going to uh lead the
giant rollup you're going to be like you
know what
yeah you know like you and I you right
doing thinking about these things and
bringing imagination to the sector like
let's create A1 billion a year it's a
rounding error on giving iTunes for
charity that gives Americans a website
they can go to and get up to-date really
great information on the impact that
every organization is making in in
addition to the financial data we don't
have anything like that right now you
know why my Bright Idea Dan when I was
running for president um I I was going
to give everyone uh$ 200 philanthro
dollars that you can just give to any
nonprofit you want any given year use it
or lose it and it just turns everyone
into a customer and if you help them it
it actually pays and it grows the sector
because it's like who
cares yeah but first we got to give get
people thinking right right we got to
get them giving to the correct
organizations like I would go and speak
in philanthropy classes all the time
undergrad philanthropy classes and the
class had 10 grand to give away and they
bring me in at the end of the semester
and it would screw everything up because
they realized they had been asking all
the they were ready to give away all
this money and they had asked all the
wrong questions they had asked about
overhead and about about salaries but
but you know like you and I are
imaginative people we're creative people
and that's what we need in government
you know forget about all this
moralizing and where do you stand on all
the moral issues can we basically agree
that we're all decent people we just
have different approaches to it let's
give the money to the creat cretive
people to the imaginative people like I
look at I look at the big foundations in
America there's a trillion dollars in
the corpuses of America's foundations
and you take the biggest ones the the
MacArthur's and the Annie casy and the
Fords and those like why don't those 10
leaders get together and say hey why
don't we each put in five million bucks
this year it is a rounding error not
even on our Corpus on our grant making
has 5050 million bucks and let's buy
half the ads on the Super Bowl and educ
at the American public about the
importance of the nonprofit sector in
America let's put some of our money
together and build a robust iTunes uh
for charity let's do structural things
that change philanthropy in the sector
that's why we need something like a
department of philanthropy because that
imagination is just not forthcoming and
we desperately need it well if if we
wind up in the White House you'll
definitely be the Secretary of fanthropy
if that's the job that you want um so
one of the major accomplishments of the
last few years which you were probably
cheering the way I was um was The
Cutting of child poverty in half in 2021
did you see this like because one of the
talking points you have um is look guys
like we've been doing all this nonprofit
stuff um and poverty is essentially
constant uh nonprofits proportion of the
econom is essentially constant like what
are we really doing in 2021 the
government came along and gave every
American Family below I think 75k in
earnings uh 4400 or $500 per kid per
month so if you were a poor family and
had two kids you you might have gotten
$112,000 that year uh and that haved
child poverty uh it went um to nutrition
and education like all to the extent we
could measure these things everything
got better uh domestic violence and uh
an abuse went down uh it was like the
greatest thing we'd done and then
because of our political dysfunction we
undid it uh and child poverty shot up
again from 5% to 12% um when the child
tax credit ended in in 22 and the the
child tax credit um when they did it it
was it was a government move um the
annual cost was maybe 100 billion doll
per year and that's why they undid it
because they were like oh like too much
spending and Joe Mansion was like ah
it's bad and then they got rid of it now
120 economists signed a letter saying we
should keep doing this is like the best
thing we've ever done best thing we've
done in a generation on poverty and then
you know obviously it died um so that to
me showed what can happen it's like like
the government took a big swing and it
actually haved child poverty and if we
kept doing it child poverty would be
lower today than than it has been in in
Generations it it has child poverty but
it doesn't tell us um a lot about the
rest of the story like what's going on
with these kids education what going on
with these kids' health does it
necessarily mean that they're going to
lead productive lives and and I know you
don't disagree with me here this is
where the nonprofit sector comes in um
two points I want to make number one um
you need R&D you need research on
development what research and
development on what approaches work for
domestic violence what approaches don't
what approaches work for mentoring
teenage gang members what approaches
don't literacy recidivism you name it
where is that R&D going on at the level
of government it isn't there aren't R&D
departments there aren't Skunk Works for
those things the nonprofit sector is
that right that's where dat we don't ask
enough of the nonprofit sector to your
point you're right it's like we should
be like hey all right guys let's like
see what the best practices are in
solving this very difficult problem and
then as soon as one of you is doing it
then we should like pump resources into
pump resources into that right and and
and I mentioned no kid hungry share our
strength as an example they were growing
nicely they were making grants to food
Banks all over the United States and
they decided growth isn't enough we want
to tackle ending child hunger in America
by the year 2030 and they went about it
very intelligently they started working
with states with um the governor's
administrations unlocking Federal money
that had been allocated for food
programs that in many cases the states
didn't even know they had and working
with teachers unions who here to for did
not want to be uh working as B
babysitters for Mak in the cafeteria for
kids eating their breakfast and lunches
they solved both of those problems in in
in many states and statistically ended
child hunger in 35 States and they're
still working on it now Billy will
admits look these kids are still food
insecure they're I mean these kids are
still living in poverty they they're
still poor but they're eating you know
and and and this is an example where a
nonprofit LED government to the solution
so I think that you know government
shouldn't be the master of our Destinies
it should be an instrument of our dreams
and nonprofits can help lead government
to the places where the money is really
going to make an impact because all all
government does is allocate money
without really knowing in in many cases
where that money is going to be
effective and where it isn't I I mean we
couldn't F we couldn't calculate what's
been wasted what problems could have
been solved but the money was instead
wasted you know on God knows
what this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a new year time to make
yourself better rested more energized
and a great way to do that is with a
helix Sleep mattress I took their quiz
and I said you know what I roll around a
lot I sleep in my back I need a lot of
support and I got matched with a dawn
Lux mattress that has become a game
changer not just for me but for my kids
it's their favorite mattress even though
it wasn't designed for them Helix will
now actually tailor mattresses
specifically for Big and Tall customers
and for kids they have a 100 night trial
you can try the mattress for 3 months
send it back and ATT 10 to 15-year
warranty it's the top rated Mattress By
wired and many other Publications don't
take my word for it try it out for
yourself Helix is offering 20% off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yangang and use code Helix partner 20
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts
[Music]
now well I I mean that's what I was um
meant to pursue when I was running
Venture for America running a nonprofit
it's like you say okay I get some risk
capital in from some philanthropists and
then some foundations come in and fund
it and then ideally you show results and
then if you show results then maybe the
government says oo that that's awesome
end up ends up funding like that that's
what you were meant to have as this uh
progression uh but I I mean that that's
you know uh something of a Rarity as you
and I know it's like most nonprofits
never get to a point where where where
they're doing that sort of thing and
they're not doing advocacy they're not
represented on Capitol Hill so there's
literally no communication link you know
between the nonprofit sector and certain
and certainly the federal government and
and so we think government government
government has to solve all these
problems well let's define Sol Finance
maybe but Sol I don't think that's where
I am man that's where I am government
can like Finance but
not not all it's like well what you know
it's just they're just groups of human
beings government is just a group of
human beings nonprofit is a group of
human beings apple is a group of human
beings Tesla is a group of human beings
how come we let H H how come we have
watched Tesla be the company that TR we
government didn't do that government
didn't know how to make the the the
global automobile Fe Fleet electric
Tesla did why do we think that people
could not be as industrious in the
nonprofit sector there's no logic to
that it's irrational there's no proof um
if we un relased it it could begin to it
could be begin to create the kind of
society we want will there be equality
will everybody have the same amount of
money no maybe 500 years from now
someone will figure out what the answer
to that is but right now what we
struggle is we don't want to see
suffering on the streets anymore we
don't want to see people you know with
open wounds on the street we don't want
to see people who have you know are
mentally ill wandering the streets
without closing we don't want to see
kids who are hungry we want to solve for
that 10% that that that group that Bucky
Fuller said you know no one and nothing
left out let's do it we can do it we're
capable of doing it dude unfortunately
that 10% I feel like is is growing in
America today like people like the the
tenuousness um so here's the vision the
game plan if you will the government
provides something of a foundational
layer to and then uh and then you have
the nonprofit sector driving Innovation
and solving uh human developmental
problems uh and issues um and we need to
unlock the sector's ability to actually
solve problems and grow it needs to be
in my opin I agree with you like
meaningfully much much dramatically
larger than it is today yeah uh now now
the economy and this is one of the
things again that drove me to to run for
president which I would certainly
encourage you to consider doing um the
economy is $25
trillion a year now yeah uh and and so
if you look at it in that context you're
like holy crap well you know it's like
that the biggest nonprofits uh operate
at hundreds of millions level I mean I
don't know how many billion dollars
unless it's higher unless it's higher
head but the biggest you know the World
Visions of the world they're like they
do
400 they do four billion not 400 they
four billion a year you know Apple does
that every 60 seconds you know Apple's
bringing in $4 billion every day where
closing in again on A3 trillion market
cap you know yeah so we have to tackle
both these problems at the same time and
God love you for uh tackling the
philanthropic sector uh and trying to un
unlock human potential really because I
think that's what makes you tick is like
you know people are capable of more uh
and we we have to help people achieve
what they're capable of you know we saw
that with the AIDS rides like the the
aid rides were not 5 kilometer walks or
runs or rides were seven days and you
had to sleep in a tent for six nights
and we didn't recruit athletes we
recruited average people who were
yearning yearning to express you know
people are terrified that they're going
to die and that hero or heroine in them
is never going to find expression that
they're going to be buried with their
potential still in them people are tired
of being asked to do the least they can
possibly do they want to be asked to do
the most they could possibly do on
behalf of the causes that have broken
their hearts and the great issues of our
time we minimize people human beings
have the most incredible potential and
we need to speak to that as a nation and
I think one of the ways we need to speak
to that that we haven't talked about is
with Apollo like goals you know why we
got to the Moon in nine years because
John Kennedy said a nine-year deadline
you know how long it would have taken if
he didn't we still would not be there
right because deadlines Drive urge and
conversations they force you to talk
about things other than the weather and
in the absence of deadlines you
literally get to talk about the weather
and the Patriots and the Red Sox you
know um and and I think where is the
serious deadline for the end of cancer
where is the serious deadline for the
end of homelessness in the city of San
Francisco because you set if you didn't
have a deadline if your kid didn't need
to be at school at 8:00 what chance in
hell is there that they would be ready
for school at 8:00 right it's just a
basic principle of living um and we do
not apply it to the great social issues
of our time and I think people should
study Apollo and one of the the great
things about Apollo is it was
unbelievably well documented you can get
a PhD in the in the achievement of the
APO Impossible by studying how we got to
the Moon in nine years without a
computer any more powerful than a
calculator yeah it is wild to think
about it's true yeah uh it's unlocking
human potential
entrepreneurship activism kindness Arts
creativity congratulations uh on your
work uncharitable the movie is an
awesome achievement I know that uh you
must love seeing people watch it and
then how they respond to it how can
people support you your work and
hopefully unleashing the entire
nonprofit sector to the betterment of
humanity right now get people to see
that movie get as many people as you
know to see the movie host a viewing at
your home host a screening in your
organization host a screening at your
company um it will be streaming uh
January 1 one right now it's it's still
playing in theaters you can go to
uncharitable
docomo you can contact us and we can
help you with a theater bio but we we
didn't make the movie as something to to
uh be overstepped in the in the name of
something bigger we made the movie
because we felt that this is the
educational tool that is going to be
required to change the way the culture
thinks about things and you need to
change the way the culture thinks about
things right that's what we had to do
with seat belts it's what we had to do
with smoking I'm gay it's what we had to
do with gay marriage you need to change
at the retail level at the Grassroots
Community level the way everyone thinks
and then policy makers will follow suit
and then the media will follow suit
that's why we made a movie so the answer
is go see the movie get as many people
as you can to see the movie I certainly
recommend uncharitable the movie it's
impossible not to walk away a changed
person really because you watch this
movie you're like oh it it makes certain
things make sense to you in a way they
had not before congratulations on that
and the work that it reflects uh Dan
pada man you were my hero after that Ted
talk because imagine me as a youngish
nonprofit founder and then watching that
Ted Talk uh and you're still the same
hero you always were well thanks Andrew
and then then our past diverged and you
became this huge Global figure so good
for you I mean the gumption that it the
gumption that it took to say I'm going
to run for president and the success you
had with creating a platform my hats off
to you as well man well thank you you
know when social entrepreneurs
occasionally see me and it's like oh
like you because I I I knew a bunch of
them from the circle I mean you know
like a bunch of us knew each other so it
made me happy because I actually think
that that's my tribe absolutely yeah
well good well I look forward to all the
things we and others are going to do
together to create the kind of world
that we really want and really deserve
yeah uncharitable the movie is going to
help speed up the path there
congratulations Dan all right Andrew
thanks